ce qui est bien avec les commentaires
sur internet c'est que au moins les gens
ils disent pas tout et n'importe quoi
or déjà ce qui est génial c'est les mecs
qui s'engueulent et qui se fight par
commentaires interposés c'est pas la
façon la plus virile du monde ne se
battre quand même je me suis peut-être
avec un mec je vais te démonter as tu
t'es battu dans la rue non sur youtube
sur internet les gens ils baissent pas
leurs noms donc c'est le seul endroit au
monde où tu pourra lire par exemple ça
nul on peut pas dire ça comme ça dans la
vraie vie
sur youtube il existe la team des
pousses vers la team des pouces verts
c'est des mecs qui s'en foutent du bac
des meufs
eux ils ont ils ont un objectif dans ma
vie où je tape commentaire nicolas je
suis enceinte je m'en bats les couilles
si on top commentaire le regard d'une
femme
le sourire de ton gamin est rentable
commentaires ça vaut bien plus que tout
ça c'est vrai qu'il est quand même pas
beaucoup de gens qui mettent des pousses
rouge m 1 pouces rouge c'est quand même
une action un peu plein de haine un peu
vénère je me demande à quoi ressemblent
les mecs qui mène 7 pouces rouge
je déteste les mourres je vous et tous
[Musique]
booth rouge
oh je jouis après il ya les snobe les
snobs il met un type de commentaire
c'est un mot pas plus une onomatopée bon
après il ya les geeks 8 et 10 ans c'est
le mec qui met plein de smiley comme si
les gars il avait plein d'expressions du
visage en même temps oh oh oh moi je
suis le smiley blasé ou alors ils
mettent pleins de xd xd ça veut dire que
vous n'êtes plus le mec derrière son
écran elle est comme ça max bas après il
ya l'intello centriste moi qui ai ni
trop la nitro là c'est le mec qui veut
calmer je veux pas trop pour ce qui
concerne sur youtube
amen après il ya les vieux collier un
vieux qui fait un commentaire sur
internet
tulle gris tout de suite
irène s'est quand même chic internet les
américains sur youtube quand il tombe
sur une vidéo française ils font
toujours le même commentaire
frem saxe et pas mal de mecs aussi
qu'ils essaient de faire leur pub par le
biais de commentaires youtube
écoutez c'est pareil oui vous tapez
marié vialle et foerster mais qui met
des first [ __ ] j'suis first [ __ ] bon
évidemment il ya les donneurs de leçons
ce qui est marrant avec eux c'est que ça
perd toute crédibilité quand c'est
bourré de fautes d'orthographe
[Musique]
lui ou moi il a compris après les rageux
les rageux
rien n'y faire bon après y'a le mec qui
s'est trompé de site bien combien est
assez poussé
après il ya le commentaire wtf mais le
meilleur commentaire internet
si elle tient si tu veux tu peux tu
abonnés à la chaîne youtube en cliquant
ici
ou alors tu peux regarder les autres
vidéos en cliquant dessus avec ta souris
mais surtout n'oublie pas d'achat un com
[Musique]